michael pena is the actor for 12 strong
he plays sergeant first class Sam Diller
and 12 strong hits theaters coming up
this Friday by the way do you get to
pick your own name of your character you
ever picked your own name um no I mean I
think I would have changed it something
more Latin what would you have called
yourself tastic I I am always amazed at
that that even Big Time actors can't
change the name of their character like
they say your name is Jimmy Lipper yeah
I'm surprised those guys can't do that
I'm not a big-time actor I don't want
myself a big-time actor like it must be
tough for those guys what do people say
on the street when they see you hey
what's up woman
[Laughter]
so anybody Latin then you play along
with them sure buddy I sign it as Erik
Estrada you know I had people who were a
guy who came up to me and he goes stuart
scott love you man and stuart of course
african-american and i just said yeah
boo yeah like I you know I've had
somebody say hey hey chris burrman Scott
Van Pelt yeah yeah yeah sure why not is
so is there a movie that they couple you
with when people come up to you where
they want to ask you certain things
about a certain movie I mean do you know
what it's been a cool transition because
it you know it started off with crash
and then shooter World Trade Center like
you know end of watch
you know ant-man those kind of movies
and so it's mainly movies about
I mean maybe questions about that but I
think I think ant-man gets the most
questions because people were like those
those fans are like they're they're
diehard fans and they really want to
know everything Marvel and I don't know
everything Marvel but when you were
first pitched ant-man right I could like
what goes through you know Paul Rudd is
you know I'm sure great to couple with
ya with but you know when somebody says
here's the premise and every action was
awesome oh you got it right away the
thing was is that Marv
like Edgar Wright's the one that wrote
me the you know the both depart for me
and so someone from Marvel comes and
instead of you saying like give me the
weekend to read it the guy was standing
outside of my hotel room while I was
filming fury waiting for me to finish
the script and I'm a slow reader so it
took me like four hours because there's
so much description you know in those
kind of movies so you know I had to have
an answer right away so it took me you
know an afternoon and then I know that
uh the topic of another ant-man movie
has come up right but I mean just in
mere form of questioning okay where
you're like you know if there's a third
would you want to be in it and I was
like of course and then Mike Oliver
lines Michael Pena confirms there's a
third movie I'm like you're Chicago Bear
fan I'm yeah yeah how much better how
much are you a Chicago Bear I mean I
really am I'm like I go to as many games
as I can and now because I live in Los
Angeles and I'm like you know I've never
been the guy that like my best friend is
is a guy that like every Sunday you know
he would get the paper and like he knows
all the names and and you know all the
positions and he's really really
involved the only thing that I have ever
been I mean I know because of fantasy
football are you in fantasy yeah I'm in
fantasy what's the name of your team
Apache butter knife it's tough and
gentle at the same time it that sounds
like a band yeah like a punk rock band
yeah Apache oh the Apache butter nice
ladies and gentlemen yeah yeah but but
are you are you in with other actors
celebrities it was it was with Paul Rudd
it was the Marvel like we had totally
geeking out right now yeah I was looking
at Marvel kind of like reliever yeah I
mean but I did I did I think I did okay
I might get picked up by John Watson
fuller you know like on the waiver wire
and I thought that and they told they
won me five games in row and they're the
reason that I but then he got hurt yeah
some I mean he got hurt in practice
which is yeah but yeah but he was just
crushing it the kid looks amazing like
he looks really comfortable in the
pocket and then I'm like I just saw him
play a couple games and I just know he's
a lot of fun yeah and his coach said
look he's the next Michael Jordan and
nobody
and you got any penalties calls against
no no the only way can stop himself is
to get injured Michael plays Sam Diller
in 12 strong hits theaters this Friday
explain your role what it would
attracted you to this well I mean I'm
one of the twelve and they're basically
elite soldiers you know they're Green
Berets that go in and they volunteered
you know September 12th to go in and
this one it was a different tactic
instead of just putting like you know
thousand troops on the ground they put
you know they basically dropped off 12
and their elite soldiers you know Green
Berets and so they're they're kind of
like free thinking you know soldiers and
so they you know they work in
conjunction to take over this city
that's kind of that would be the
breeding ground the training ground for
you know terrorists so and in three
weeks they you know they were able to do
this but you can't it's like when I
watch people portray a baseball player
or you know an athlete in a movie and
you go well I don't know what do they
really look like they could have played
when you you know you're gonna have to
portray a green beret
right like you you can't kid the CGI
can't help you with being a green break
yes it can it can whoa no I mean I mean
the way you look
yeah me we or me we're stacked with
clothes and stuff and III think the
thing that you got a you know focus on
is like what can I really portray what
can what you know what can be a
potential strengths and I think that
that's like camaraderie you know like
how you're just you know talking to the
guys and the relationships and you know
cracking jokes and the type of jokes
that you do I mean I think that's what I
focused on okay and and you know and
thank God that I was you know some of
the guys really liked it he's again
that's how we really talk and you know
that's that's my only contribution to it
like I'm that Thor I'm that Chris heaven
foot nine he's a little too good-looking
isn't he like there's certain guys where
you go that's not fair yeah and then
when my wife says it I'm like you know
are you gonna be in narcos I am I am
yeah they they told us not to say
anything and then all of a sudden there
was an announcement
on on social media no / deadlines or
what and what role you plan I can't tell
you I can't tell you you'll be all ready
you know it's said a little bit I mean
they're not gonna take you out of it
yeah have you already shot it I shot two
episodes and I'm returning that's you
know that's why I have the long issue
hair for me especially like yeah are you
a good guy or bad guy oh yeah that I
can't tell you do you want to be a good
guy or bad what's tougher to play a good
guy or bad guy I think it's about the
same thing I'm like it's just but I
would want to be a bad guy just to see
how bad I can't okay in life or just in
well maybe in life - but I like there's
part of you that goes I always go back
to you know when I see a Walter White
and Breaking Bad oh that you like what
brings out that evil in you even ISM as
an actor right something has to go man
I'm gonna go in my deep recesses here
and bring out somebody I don't know even
exist in me you know what that's that's
really interesting that you say that cuz
I'm like sometimes in Hollywood it's
it's the opposites you know that that
like you know like Michael Shannon is a
really nice guy yeah some of these guys
that play these bad bad guys are really
like very very gentle nice people
Michael Shannon
he seems like scary yeah I mean he's
intense but he's a really nice guy you
know and I've met a lot of these guys
like so-called you know bad boys in
movies that are you know nice and then
the other people that are supposed to be
nice
well he was in the shield I think I was
Shannon in the shield - no no he was not
I did movie with that guy
Boardwalk Empire was he was in the
Boardwalk Empire yeah I did my first
movie I went to an open call and I you
know my best friend's mom says hey
you're good at imitating when II try
acting so I'm like ass good I went to an
open call I didn't get the part but they
sucked me in as an extra and I thought I
made it at that time and then during
rehearsals you know
Michael Shannon was the kid next to me
and he you know stood up did his thing
and then went away and then the
following day he wasn't there and I said
what happened he got fired he got fired
from that show so the my first job my
first job was a big one that I didn't
get and he got fired from so that was 22
years ago in Chicago who do you purse
I used to like I went to the you know
mayor high school and I would
impersonate like the nuns and the
priests also not you you don't do it
where you're doing Denzel Washington or
you know no I never did that I never
even thought of that I'm like there I
was just getting like seriously I was
getting a quarter for these
impersonations and I don't need I can't
even do him that a quarter a quarter but
like I didn't grow up with a lot of
money I went to this you know this is
like prep school and they you know these
kids had like Corvettes at 16 believe it
I was to me it was a whole nother world
like they would say Michael oh do the
impersonation of the nun and we'll give
you a quarter yeah exactly yeah that's
what it was
I don't remember it now but I also saw
where you're a big golfer
yeah I love it okay are you legit three
handicap um I'm a 3.5 so I'm not a
widget three handicap but that's I don't
know how they you know what like you
know cuz I'm an actor I'll play for like
I have a month off and I just you know
I'll go in shooting like 85-82 and then
you know after if you if you're playing
two times a week then you're perfect
you're gonna get better and then if I
you know if I have two rounds of 74 at
my home course no all of a sudden I'm a
three handicap or Tom I don't I don't
think you're gonna lose money I'm gonna
lose money every time yeah yeah most
famous person you play golf with oh um
wow I think Dan Quayle
nice going yeah very nice man I was I
played with him at the Bob Hope okay
yeah I played with him in Tahoe oh you
did yes yeah he was a really nice guy
and I was playing bad I was hungover and
then I have to I have to watch my
language like you you know you're in
Tahoe they just pair you with whoever oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah view played at
Pebble but I've never played there but I
you know what it was like I don't I
don't mean to show off but I I got a
hole-in-one at the Hope at the Bob Hope
yeah with the you know in Dan Quayle was
one of the part of the foursome and they
got it on video they did yes
yes you have that the rest of your life
the rest of my you know what's funny I
you know the crash won the Oscar like
couple years before that and I got like
300 text messages and just you know
congratulating me blob of letters in
that 10 nn then I know I got a thousand
texts man
for being way more I'm like I'm in the
wrong business maybe yeah
well you know that more important you
know more people watching sportscenter
care about that yeah I know Matt Dillon
was great and crazy he was creepy people
forget about Matt Dillon and using
whenever I say Matt Dillon they go you
mean Matt Damon I go no no Matt Dillon
was there before Matt Damon yeah yeah
that's right it was great I mean yeah he
had a I mean he still has like a great
career I remember him you know his
movies in the 80s and then you know he
played that that crazy cop in crash yeah
I think he was nominated for an Oscar am
i right I think so to have four people
computers here yeah well they're not
listening to by the way I think I you
know what I'm glad I chose this shirt
because if it's like the uniform around
here yeah right yeah you could have worn
flannel Michael I mean which i think is
about pretty it's pretty close yeah this
is standard standard issue Michael Pena
plays sergeant first class Sam Diller
and 12 strong hits theaters this Friday
Congrats on your success thank you Scott
appreciate them for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]